you think that this year is a very
important year because of dollars
meeting is happening and matter if
you're recommending a wig because
everybody astonished as a crisis but
also everybody respite to think how we
can inject this practice and one of the
opportunities that's happening right now
is the advisors help us to think and
which are the fastest ways to go in the
direction of low-carbon economy and I
think that in several species here we
can see the commitment of several
leaders and Statesman's towards
commitment with climate change and
action in the direction of a new diaper
growth of the economy and the second
thing that I think is important is
rethinking ethic and business more and
more we have to have a spare and see
collaboration and the lessons learned
from the crisis help us to understand
that the mid next step the egg air after
the crisis will be a much more committed
economy to ethics and values that can
support trust